[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to gamespot
live i'm persia and today's stream
is sponsored by xbox and we're going to
be playing some destiny 2 beyond light
with
crafty what's up crafty welcome thanks
for joining us how's it going persia
pretty good pretty good excited to check
out some story missions
and the new glass we strike a little bit
later
and kind of going over all the things
that beyond light is bringing to the
table
and you know kind of showing to some of
our viewers that it's a great time to
get back into destiny too
uh yeah so um i'm gonna be
okay late wait um i'm gonna be doing the
first few story missions and then we're
gonna check out the glassway strike
did i just uh
okay we're good
awesome so you are hopping on a
different character than usual to start
out some of these
people of the last city yeah you have
playing through the story
devastating blow but uh we gotta play
titan
no
and i've got chat up on my phone which
is kind of weird
and i'm kind of new we have lost contact
anyone from my channel if you go over to
gamespot's youtube channel
make sure you guys behave in the
meantime
it's gonna be a good time and for
anybody who
maybe used to play destiny 2 and haven't
played in a while there's a ton of new
stuff
with beyond so it's going to be a good
time to check that out this time
and new weapons new abilities
i mean i've been having fun with it if
you like destiny you'll like the online
[Music]
i definitely think i would yeah for sure
all right we're good chad are you guys
having a good day
good morning i know it's a different
kind of stream
there's no intro there's no chilling i
mean we're still chilling but
no uh we don't get our talk terrible
things born out in the darkness yeah
we're jumping
right into it jump right in
every moment brings them closer the cam
is small
yes it's kind of you kind of like it
though my future does not begin
here but yours does
i mean i already saw chat saying they
show up to see your beautiful face
that's my chat as long as the stuff's
there let's go
and it all with a splinter
oh man
it's been a long time since i've read
chat off my phone i'm gonna keep it real
it feels like the old days right where
is this like whatever works whatever
yeah for sure
do um you guys care if i call out subs
or anything
i can't really see mud or do you just
want to chill
um we might have to chill unfortunately
we support you guys thank you for
creating crafty
in return earth
the great machine elixir and
the human so we have our opening
cinematic going right now
but can you tell us maybe about some of
the new
weapons and abilities with the spaces um
well they added a like it's not really a
new weapon it's the no time to explain
the strangers pulse rifle
which is really really good the gun
actually slaps
um but yeah each uh each class has a new
subclass
stasis um pretty it's pretty much
ice though it's pretty fun to use
i i've been enjoying it
with my time with it
dude barracks is such a weirdo man
got one more
now they wanted to make sure you could
see it in all of its glory
why did the darkness invite us here
my titan dude you're quiet today yeah
i tell you get to know love we keep
coming face to face with darkness
and every time we fail to stop it which
is so
yeah we're streaming at 1080p how does
it look on the stream by the way
on twitch
and also okay so we can totally call you
guys out
sorry it was cool so let's go
chad we get like 50 to like 100 gifted
let's go check it out coming from time
to time
it's your time chat
i might have to pull weapons over maybe
i've tracked barracks's distress signal
beyond the ridge that will be fine hurry
you can make it work he instigated them
he's equally responsible for cade's
death
that's the plan after him since no
wonder he's hiding on a desolate moon
let us get in
i really like europa though oh yeah no i
was saying going through this
part of the mission you don't actually
have stasis yet right no
that comes later on
sneaking in a little little bit of
morning cardio oh yeah
while we take this ride for those of you
in the game spot chat
uh we're mentioning some of those basis
abilities but later we're going to be
checking out
the glassway strike and we'll be able to
see all of those abilities
in action which is going to be pretty
interesting get to see a little bit of
before and after
with some new stuff yes this is
definitely fun to use
something like completely new and
different in destiny is um
always nice
these fallen had an unfamiliar house
symbol what are we dealing with
someone's been staying here there's
traces of
yeah i know i saw the 12 the 12 looks
good it looks really really good
actually
a lot of good changes even tied clothes
golden age colony here on europa
whoever was here was using it to track
back oh awesome yes
in our chat they're playing destiny for
the first time and it's pretty difficult
i've got the singles nice
that's awesome it's not far let's hurry
remember the first time i played destiny
in d1
okay it's just like there's really no
game like it
super sick
if you think back to that day one would
you have imagined it
being where it is now uh
no definitely not for the game and for
me honestly
that's the beauty of it
i'm actually getting owned on the first
mission dude
[Laughter]
i'm actually a pve potato
oh my god
dude i'm literally on hard mode
oh okay that guy came out
all right let's go
yeah first try we actually own
it this time if we don't get to him
first someone else will
if it's not already too late
wait darkness it's close i feel it but
it's different somehow
what okay
i know do i keep moving i'm sorry
change difficulty in settings okay
is it on hard mode now
where is it let's just put it on the
hardest
difficulty possible you got it i believe
the buildings find it
every few fights we get a nice little
movie
this
cling to your machine guard
with this power
we make our own fate
oh
make an example of him he has three more
workouts
well i think he's going to die actually
see you'd much rather be the guy doing
the freezing than being froze
that is true that is definitely true
now they all have to pay the price for
what they do here we come
i don't remember what top tree is on
titan for striker
but we'll find out
not superman is it
[Music]
no more guns no fruit for it fire away
wait a second i'm picking up more shadow
on the fallen columns
oh
i swear this is what happened last time
okay
okay we're good we're good we're good
not so fast we heard your message
darkness walks among us what do you mean
there is no time they are coming
verricks asks for your protection once
more i will
uh yep i'm just hanging out you know
hosting a bit
in different you know circumstances we
would have been able to bring
crafty like to gamespot hq and then we
could just like play together but
hey this is the next first thing they'll
get to work together which is super
awesome for sure
okay we actually turned up now we own
yeah we're just giving you guys some
entertainment
the pve god right here oh it feels good
but know that our work here has only
just begun
let's go we win those mission completed
i really can't remember how long into
the mission basis i think it's like
pretty deep though
well you're uh going through them pretty
quickly might be able to get
sneak a few more story missions in there
before we hop into the street
you do not trust you guys are witnessing
a turning point next thing you know
is gonna be the only thing crappy yeah
i'm just gonna
start maining story missions are you
guys ready for that
on every character every stream is just
me making new accounts doing story
missions
unifier of the houses
chat's already calling for speed runs
if she is not stopped she will destroy
us all you must go
barracks will help you find your way
nice
okay
the new kill
let's go
all right on to the next one the power
aramis used to trap you was that
darkness so what was the new item you
just unlocked
timeline's vertex fusion rifle
so the ankle weights are off now yeah
now
oh did you get a gift dude
now you literally have the best emotes
on twitch now
[Music]
thick estonia
i think we i think we still have
halloween emotes right
that oh yeah i think
i had christmas emotes until like
september
i think um
the emo game is haunting
awesome i feel so much more powerful
oh yeah
this is what remains of eventide clovis
praise europa
i feel like i'm definitely going to use
one that's a total insect
it's very red in here or you're dying
maybe a little both with that explosion
here we go
chat is so so tiny
i like how they made this map or this
like new destination all
ice but still somehow made all the eyes
look different
yeah for sure the new area is like super
pretty i like it a lot
that doe is that where you live
oh my god no dude the flank
oh bro i don't know how i do it i really
don't
and there's no response here either i'm
actually the worst
yeah i gotta see a coffee break on that
one i think i'm like
at low power oh my god
okay we're gonna have to sweat
it's the only way to go
dude
chat must know what i'm doing wrong i am
just getting destroyed
but they're too small
all right
oh god
okay
that was though i've never seen a titan
finisher i was actually really sick
how many hours do you think you have in
destiny
um i think i had like 3 500 in disney
one
so maybe near like 5 000
and this is the first time you've seen
the finisher
yeah well they're new they're new
i don't play titan at all
i mean that's pretty cool though that
means there's just so much that you
should
experience in this game oh my god
dude great
i just started one earlier i mentioned
the death counselor and i was like we
won't need a death counter but now i'm
saying the wonder
we might need my god i do have to start
completely over dude
wow yeah maybe we do need a death
counter
i forgot we were playing demon souls
again
extra sweaty
oh my god he's reading literally
everywhere
old
and if you guys are just tuning in to uh
live today um you should know that
today's stream is
sponsored by xbox so it's super awesome
to be able to place them
destiny to be online with crafty on our
show today with their support
if you guys are enjoying what you've
seen so far it is a part of
you know a bunch of brand new content
coming into the game
um if you have played destiny before or
you've always been wanting to then now
it's a really good time to check it out
so
join us watch some more uh you know
give crappy your energy so that you can
yeah please
and a little bit later we'll be checking
out the glass made string
yeah i think i'm not sure if i've done
that yet like actually
but maybe favorite
maybe getting crafted with all the new
experiences
oh my god dude
okay this is what needs to happen
higher armor
yeah get all the gear
that's a little better
i feel it again the energy i felt
earlier it must have been aramis using
stasis
we are definitely entering sweat levels
of strafing right now
dude right like
oh my god it feels like i'm playing pvp
i'm like sliding around and like
strafing on
npc
that next level ai
i don't think i can open yet darkness
trail eremis left behind
leads right through that door but it's
locked
it's stasis yes
definitely making progress nice
yeah we're filming the montage on the on
dregs for
centuries we have been bound by them
servants to the so-called great
eric in the chat says i'm so hyped for
the update
well thanks for tuning in crafty's
showing off a bit of it for us today's
of our own
devices
today did it to our own dude breaking
free from that you gotta show them
you're a little crazy sometimes
they stay alive they're all like no no
no no
this power is a gift
one i will share
yeah i remember this from the trailer
and i was like oh wait
oh we'll rise again
good we good okay yeah we're good i was
like oh no
i remember this part from the trailer
and this is when i was like yeah i would
definitely be that
goon right there picking up this chard
our enemies they're all hyped now
the great machine will finally know
our pace
he's just a little guy it would appear
our enemies have arrived
eager to test us let's
not keep them waiting
it's like when you get like some top
tier gear or something
like all right let's go to pub so like
watch somebody with them
we're not gonna let it happen no no i'm
trying to get some top tiers
i'm calling our ship let's go oh my god
a little scary
wait what is happening
is that that's my ship that's what i'm
using
oh my god
all right
i will be doing the raid yeah on the
21st i'm gonna get that world first
definitely
definitely
nice you wanna um
tell maybe our viewers a little bit more
about that
um yeah so the new raid comes out i
think it's called the deep stone crypt
it could be wrong pretty sure it's deep
sun
something stunned but it comes down the
21st of november at 10 a.m and they're
gonna do like a world first race i fled
from her
and they're like capping power power
levels for that too to make it
great so that people that just grind all
day every day
aren't like at a huge advantage being
like super over levels
so i thought that was really cool i'm
pretty sure it's the first time that
they've done that
so i thought that was like a really good
call kind of making it a
double playing ground for everyone i
will not and then whoever does end up
getting world first they give like a
really cool
oh they've done that the last few times
have they really i didn't know that
still though
okay let me get oh yeah this full circle
owns
feeling confusion
sounds like my everyday life
the spider who waits on the shore
he keeps treasures trapped
get a jacket irl for being actual i
thought
i thought everyone got the jacket if you
complete it by a certain time
and then you can just buy it i hoped it
would
when you win first place easy chances
am i going the wrong way oh
dude i remember this one i literally
left and
where i have to go is right where i just
was
okay
oh yeah this is where we got that guy
out of the ice
right where i literally just was
you good
power's going barracks good
two
right here too
okay barracks that's two all right
one more did you hear that
sounded like voices what
um we have a question from our chad eric
wants to know
if this is the first playthrough of the
story which characters
should remain or work on um
warlocks are really really good right
now um chad i don't know if you guys
like they they did some hot fixes today
um for warlocks so i don't know if
they're still as good as they were
but i i want to say warlock's still the
best
chat will know better though
yeah i think we're locking hunter
probably would be
would be the move i'm not a huge titan
it's them they're here we're just giving
crafty a challenge
today like i have to play titan
you answered we kept you waiting long
enough
come
nothing more than a soldier asked again
and again
to do its bidding so we want to thank
you
with a gift to help you finally take
control
he's so angry in his little window
what do you mean
my little window dude
yeah this cutscene is super dope
like when i'm playing i actually in my
head imagine all of my fights this
episode yeah
that's you right
[Music]
the slo-mo there away
[Music]
yeah ouch
what an entrance and here comes our
guardian
right on time right on time
i'm hyped
dude right like if they just made movies
be sick um okay
so we think strike now
yeah let's hop into it
mess around with stasis yeah
definitely want to see some of that in
action but this is also your first time
running
this strike as well so i think you know
what to expect in terms of how long
it'll be
i think the strike is is like the very
last ray mission
if i if i remember chris i'm not
positive though it could be my my first
death
i am not sure
did you still want to uh invite someone
in to help
oh i should be okay actually i should be
fine
you're feeling good after a couple of
story missions
oh yeah we're ready warmed up we're
super ready
oh it actually puts me with people
anyway
okay
well let's see which lucky people are
gonna get
matched up with the real crafty who gets
to play with
i don't know that was us not gonna lie
it's like the real ones will know
it's time
all right let's check this out get to
see the stasis abilities now for those
of you
who are tuning in and haven't had a
chance to see any of the story or the
new abilities we're definitely gonna get
to see some of that
with this strike pretty cool throwing
some ice
like you got to see it in the cut scene
he's been watching all the streams but
now
see it in action
all right squad let's go
the vets are attempting another
incursion shut them down
where's radio wave going bro
what's our boy doing like you got
matched up with one
like speed runner and then one person to
fight everything
that's it now he wants to do he just
wanted to kill like the three guys
you know efficiency
any enemy behind
trying to level up
this game looks so good yeah
that was like one of the the biggest
things when um
when d2 came out on pc it's just like a
massive upgrade from playing on like
30fps consoles
and game looks so good
moving swiftly here
at least now if i die my boys can revive
me
oh my god
there it is
deleted
yeah easy peasy
oh god
dude
radio waves back here chilling
why am i level one hold on
i'm actually confused dude
this guy's 20 that's 68
mine said one
good old game spotlight throwing a
challenge i'm just kidding
it says that for you okay it's a bug
elizabeth you must know why clovis built
the portal yeah it's like you're still
melting them inside
it's like dude why didn't i why do they
get reset
but we good we good he would have told
you he was saving humanity
collecting the radiolarian fluid from
the vex that came through was the prime
purpose
i wanted it shut down clovis wouldn't
have it
once again he flew too close to the sun
and once again the rest of us paid for
it
bastard
parkour
oh yeah
so cool
[Applause]
i actually just learned how to do
finishers yesterday like not even just
titan
oh no
oops my voice stepped on my head
he gave you the yoshi the goomba song
all right we'll be back
i can't no i can't bacon
we've only been downs twice one was
definitely not your fault
so it hardly even counts
you're good right now
dodging
you guys didn't know this is really why
we got crafty
that's that's the thing it's like when
people think pve they think me
you know i don't want to brag or
anything so i won't
fumble back right chad
you guys know what's up
i mean this run is going pretty well
i feel like we're making a good time
i might have to go for a super speed run
after
what
i just actually like that this feels
like so much more than
just like a shooter right you have all
these everything
yeah there's like a lot going on
tons of abilities get some loot
but it's not at like the sacrifice of
the gun plate
no for sure the best part real talk
destiny has like some of the best gun
play though i've ever
played in a video game straight up like
gun play in destiny is amazing
like hand cannons feel so good they
always have
oh my god oh no
yeah we i definitely did do this strike
before we did it with lupo
and he died a million times
you're like for the record me and vicky
were chillin
lupo's dying a million times
he's a big boy was like a lot of numbers
and the health bar
was doing absolutely right oh he's
actually getting melted now
oh my god
i know they're enemies but they're kind
of pretty oh my
oh
yeah they look really cool
oh god he's back
oh no man
oh
then i die a lot during the strike near
the bottom of my warlocks that somehow
do good
oh that's kind of weird
interesting
that's so much weird
okay this grenade launcher just hits
super hard
yeah oh my god bro what
they didn't like that at all not at all
dude what
oh um
we win those let's go
huge um do we want to go
back to titan
up to you we can do
i mean this one actually went pretty
quickly yes
um i was gonna say we could try to like
speed from this but i feel like that was
a pretty good speed run
i'm down to check out some more of the
story because i know we had a few people
from our chat who haven't really seen
much of it so
i'm down the hop back over there and
play a couple more of those missions
yeah that strike was honestly a lot
faster than i thought it was gonna
[Music]
head down to the stranger that titan do
you like my titan bro
new man look at that look at him looking
good
looking real good
[Music]
i mean that was definitely a good strike
run oh yeah i needed an explanation for
all this
i was expecting to add a few more deaths
to that sound
that's why i'm hoping it crashes arrival
yeah we had radio wave because that's
what may
the floodgates are open the darkness is
here
i wield it now with intent to stop our
enemies where the light cannot
your resilience within the pyramid
proves you're capable of wielding it too
before us lies what we call a ziggyrat
its purpose
is temptation to begin your training
you must give in here
take this
oh yeah we're back after the epic
entrance
yeah we are back
and if anyone is just tuning into our
stream now
then first of all thank you so much for
joining us
um our stream today is sponsored by xbox
and bungie and we're putting some
destiny
online with crafty we're checking out
some story
mission modes we just did the glass
glassway strike
um and it's been a good time so far so
stick around we're still streaming for a
bit longer
running through some more story machines
so if you want to check a bit more of
that out
if you're thinking about getting the
game it's a great time to hop in so
sit back enjoy and uh watch the best pbe
player you've ever seen actual god pbe
crazy good
i can fast travel i think
gigantic mug of water hey you guys stay
hydrated
every day
all this sweating you've been doing in
this baby
dude i am literally the worst driver
in every single game
get headshots all day but i just can't i
can't drive
do you drive irl i do i'm actually i'm
really good at driving irl
that's that's a good thing
i'm picking this in game i suck at it
it's arabis
you just have to have a steering wheel
controller right
here did you know
that before it tuned your kind it did
the same to mine
you are not special just
oh yeah this is where i get it oh let's
go
oh nice it wasn't even that
far away it was actually the perfect
time
to unlock it
so for those people in our
oh nice we've just harnessed the power
i've never used a titan once uh
i'm a fan of moves you can use those and
there's so many like vfx with the titan
one there's just
things are just flying everywhere
the impact
oh the titan like melee is super dope
oh my god
no dude
oh my god dude this thing is wild
come on you can actually like go super
far with this
let's go
oh no oh dude
no wait oh my god no
i felt like had you done that one second
sooner it might have like
got you over that energy
[Music]
it's all good we're back yeah we are
back
here to cause more destruction like it
never happened
i'm pretty sure i just killed
maybe god let's go
oh more oh no oh
god
is hold on oh my god
i didn't realize it was like that
jesus i'm a fan of that that's crazy
he's like flying everywhere
that's pretty hype chat no one told me
titan was like that come on dude
yeah you guys gotta show crafty the
truth
chad i rely on you guys let me down
thank you
right
so we can use stasis to unlock these
latches after all oh yeah
let's look inside and see if we can find
anything useful
oh wait what
i don't think i'm here
let's go back
the polls i think it's called um
yeah hailing confusion
guys name is the teabag
can it be i can
smell that poisoned power on you
yeah i will be day one rating spread so
quickly
first definitely probably do you hope to
fight aramis
with her own weapon definitely probably
walk a absolutely dangerous path
take this recklessness to philax then
but beware
she is aramis's most skilled warrior she
made her name
at twilight gang while i got chat we'd
love that map that map is so tight
opponent and she will show
herself
the bone chiller i like the names
for all the stuff like all the equipment
so epic
hailing confusion though this is a good
one
that's me a lot of the time when i'm i'm
trying to like do quests
oh oh no
living life on the edge there a little
bit
my day is going great chad how's your
day going
i hope you guys are having a good day
maybe you had some avocado toast or
something
like you're just chilling
okay yeah
we've arrived where's the party at
i make my entrance
saving avocado toast for a really bad
day i dude i actually don't remember the
last time i've had avocado toast but
i'm about it
enjoy hey
i always have to kill fallen easy peasy
it changed
what a very strong rail there
right whoever felt that because there's
a race
what are what is all that red dogs
disappear
oh hey hold on
okay i don't have it yet i'm sad
oh it's the crystals okay
oh i'm like super low level compared to
okay wait did my quest reset
oh dude i think it resets if you die
wow ouch it's tough
really really testing you here
what is in here
so here's another um question for our
chat
if you had to kind of describe each
class to fit a play style
how would you describe it like if
someone's searching for a character
but they only like to play selfie or
they like
um yes the titans kind of like it it's
technically like the
the tank class of destiny but like not
really but they're kind of more
um like it in your face a little bit
like with shoulder charge maybe like a
bunch of other
abilities that are kind of close
quarters um hunter
under has like a lot of different things
you can do like there is a there is an
invis
so you can play stealthy and i hate it i
hate it so much um
but also really good at like like with
golden gun like they just have a bunch
of different
so they're kind of like a slayer and
then um
warlocks are kind of like support but
can also slay as well
with like magic and they also have like
riffs that heal you
and like one of their supers fluffs your
damage
a lot of versatility a lot of different
things you can do
hello
i i personally wish that i would have
leveled my warlock for
i leveled hunter first but
i wish i would have gotten lost oh my
god no dude
if i die
survive all right
why are these guys such high level
i should not be here
i don't know like these guys were chill
oh we don't go there we'll just play
smart
they're just they're just testing your
abilities what's
going on
yeah see these guys are chilling we're
need to be
they just liked hanging out next to the
big guys just in case
commander said shoulder charge is the
best ability
of all time true or false crap
i hate getting shoulder charged i hate
it
it's just flying out of nowhere in one
shot you
but it is really fun to use for sure i
remember there there was a time
when i was messing around on titan and i
just uh for a full weekend in pvp all i
did was show the charge people
that was it sometimes you have to get it
out of your system
you're like you know what let me just do
it as well
get it out of the system that was
actually a good weekend i had i had the
most melee kills out of anyone in trials
for the whole weekend
i can't see anything
all this snow oh
there we go
oh no i gotta kill this guys
i don't think i was in the right spot at
all
i mean you were still taking them out
though
yeah we got it done but
super far from like the guy
i think that power that aramis has
i've never seen anything like it if she
succeeds in granting it to her entire
army
these are the coordinates i picked up on
the radio filex has troops patrolling
this area
she might be down here because we're
going to stop her
we have to
oh my god dude wait
never but i thought it was all the way
back where i just was
good
they just shattered the pieces oh my god
hello
like enjoy the scenery backups on the
way
i think i just killed them super fast
not a big deal too good
i guess it's hard to really like see how
big the map is
are able to drive around a lot but i was
just thinking back to when you're like
oh i almost ran all the way over there
and every time you get in the car i'm
like that would have been a long one
like the map is really big
um
all right send
[Music]
imagine you're one of the gyms like
falling out of the plane as you watch
everyone below you just getting shredded
like this was a mistake a titan's just
like smashing the ground blasting all
your homies
oh my god he got away
said he arrived
oh
oh dude
[Music]
just observing
what we have the vex down here just
blasting me too
okay party everybody's got a show
they're responding to a strange signal
got it
even though it did like 10 damage oh no
oh nice
okay everything's fine
okay bro he's the best in the game
oh my god
let's get it
oh
oh my god
nice
possibly depending on how long it goes
but
for everyone to know feel free to ask
any questions especially if you have
some
questions about different tv online um
because it is new
a lot of people are coming back to the
game or are interested in picking it up
for the first time so we are definitely
down to answer some of your questions
down to help you out
dude i wish i could play destiny for the
first time again
like with everything you know now or
just completely just completely like
fresh like never played
i don't feel dependent by the traveler
i feel close to the traveler what's
something you know now that you wish
nothing really i kind of like i feel
like
just not knowing things and like
exploring is like the most
fun not really anything that like
i wish i knew
but i remember like when i first started
playing destiny like we'd be on a patrol
and you'd be like checking like every
cave
looking for something
good
is hp too not tripping
do i get to go in shoot the transformer
i think that would be the same
ah yes
[Music]
true
what drives you machines on do you fight
for glory for power
my elixir fight for the fight itself
there is nothing beyond it let me teach
you this lesson
i think this is boss fight oh nice
yeah anyway send off the boss battle
oh no oh
god
noah from our chat said what shotgun is
that um hold on
we'll show it in action a couple of
times before
oh yeah it's the bone chiller
i've never seen
epic
oh god what
oh that hurt
let's go
machine
another splintered house are you sure in
the back
[Music]
like the bone chiller does kind of own
it's definitely chilling them both
that's true
pretty epic yeah
yeah this guy's thinking the same thing
up here comes the boss
oh okay his games are a little more
active
oh
way up there what's he doing
hanging out
oh my god
wait oh no oh no
dude not like this
a little oh with our parkour no worries
see this is a sign of bad leadership
guys he's letting all of his dues
get bodied and then goes up to the fight
he's a baiter oh no
he's immune dude no
no bro
no
oh oh yeah yeah
all right
oh god
oh my god no oh
dude
yeah okay okay
that was an extremely close
qualification
but we're professionals remember easy we
win those
professionals
let's go dude first try first try
absolutely flawless amazing and that is
gonna wrap up our stream today our
stream
was sponsored by xbox and bundy so
thank you so much to them for helping
make this stream happen
and thank you to crafty for joining us
any final words for your chat or
you know you were mentioning your
upcoming stream yeah
um first of all thanks for having me i
appreciate it it was a good time
um stream will continue after this on my
channel if anyone wants to check it out
um not sure what we're gonna do yet to
be honest but if you guys are interested
in
watching the uh the world first trade
race that's on the 21st of november
at 10 a.m pacific and we're definitely
gonna get it
yeah probably for sure all right thank
you
so much and thank you to the chad and um
have a good one you guys we'll see you
later
you